omicron is here and it's spreading fast
so where are we heading well confirmed
cases of omicron are rising by the day
but there are many more below the radar
one leading scientist tracking kobe told
us there are likely to be around 500
cases a day and they're doubling every
three to four days
do the maths and by christmas there
could be almost 30 000 cases of omicron
every day and by the turn of the year if
the virus keeps spreading at such a high
rate daily cases are likely to be well
past 100 000. that's the same
exponential growth rate as the beginning
of the first wave in march 2020 before
we went into lockdown so what could that
mean for the nhs well reports from south
africa suggest the variant is causing
milder disease in people who've been
vaccinated or who have immunity from a
previous coveted infection but these are
hospital admissions across the country
they're up sharply in gaoteng where
omicron took off first but there's now
even an uptick elsewhere as the virus
spreads
even if only a tiny proportion of
infections lead to hospitalizations with
a big rise in cases there can still be a
large number of admissions
here in the uk we're told time and again
that the booster jab is our best defense
against omicron
we're going to be throwing everything at
it in order to ensure that everyone
eligible is offered that booster in as i
say just over two months
so what's happened to the booster
rollout then well not a lot an average
of 380 000 people a day are having one
and the numbers are only drifting
upwards despite the call to arms just
over 20 million adults have had the
booster so far there are 26 million to
go plus another 6 million who haven't
even had their first two doses the nhs
says it will scale up the rollout in the
coming weeks with the government setting
a target of all adults being invited
booker jab by the end of january but
those vaccinations won't happen until
february immune protection won't be
secured for a fortnight after that and
with the bulk government predicting the
omicron wave will reach a sharp peak by
the end of january boosters may well
come too late for many